It's a suit that looks fit for a superhero,...
...complete with flashing lights and goggles,...
...but this exoskeleton doesn't give the wearer super strength.
I'm gonna walk really slow.
It simulates what it's like to grow old.
Genworth sellers of long-term care insurance came up with the idea.
No one really wants to talk about getting older,...
...so this experience is the tactical way to get the conversation started naturally.
And not just with the senior set.
Displaying the suit at places like the Liberty Science Center in Jersey City, New Jersey...
...gives kids something to think about.
The headset simulates what it's like to have vision disorders...
...like glaucoma and macular degeneration...
And when those cells begin to go, this is what you're left with.
Can you imagine walking around like this, Kristen?
No.
...as well as hearing impairment.
The extra weight on your back and mechanical resistance applied by the suit...
...brings home the reality of living with the muscle loss...
...and arthritis common in the elderly.